[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kim Bhd here so a
question I've seen with increasing
frequency over the past couple years is
are we at peak smartphone right now have
we hit peak smartphone you know it's
something that just seems to get said a
lot now like yeah you know smartphones
are all kind of the same I think we're
at peak smartphone it seems like every
new phone coming out these days is
basically the same as the last one with
some minor tweaks and there's no big
revolutionary jumps anymore and there's
almost never a good reason to spend a
thousand dollars on this year's phone
when you already have last year's
thousand dollar phone so yeah maybe
we've reached peak smartphone so I see
all this and as the guy that's been in
the smartphone world for a while been
reviewing them for a long time I felt
the need to chime in so I'll give my two
cents the answer to the question have we
reached peak smartphone is yes but no
you see everything you're thinking and
seeing I'm also thinking and seeing too
it's all true yes we are seeing less big
revolutionary jumps in smart phones yes
there are less crazy never-before-seen
features in phones year-over-year and
yeah it seems like the functionality and
the form factor have all sort of evolved
into just we all have glass rectangles
now glass sandwiches this is what we
call a mature market we've seen this
before you always have the greatest rate
of change at the beginning of the curve
and then as you reach the ideal or peak
smartphone it sort of slows down and
doesn't change that much year-over-year
but that's not to say we don't get some
seriously impressive improvements every
single year so rewinding a bit at the
beginning of smartphones in say the
early 2000s there were constant big new
changes and features that were literally
revolutionary we had the first phones
with a glass touchscreen and the first
phones with multi-touch that's when we
had the first time they ever put a
camera on the back and the front of the
phone that's the first phones with an
app store the first phones with desktop
class web browsers like it was just
milestone
after milestone after pillar after
pillar in a smartphone world and it was
more than just the new hardware features
it was what these new hardware features
enabled smartphone photography video
chat real-time multiplayer gaming I mean
it the list goes on so now it's easy
when you fast forward all the way to the
iPhone 11 next to the iPhone 10 R it
seems like they're almost the same phone
at a glance I mean we're all these glass
rectangles anyway but I think if you
zoom that far in you start to ignore and
lose track of the outer edges and the
peripheral that are still pushing things
forward and still enabling new things
and it's oftentimes not as drastic or as
fundamental as it used to be but it's
real for some examples in the past two
years we've recently gotten ultra
wide-angle lenses for wide photography
and videos that don't need a separate
camera or add-on lens we got in portrait
mode we've gotten high refresh rates and
new backlight technology on display as
that's more efficient and that reduced
the latency of the interface and make
everything feel significantly smoother
than it ever has computational
photography is another big one it's
taken major strides in the last couple
years with incredible HDR with the
real-time previews combining multiple
frames into one composited image nearly
instantly with a single tap of a shutter
button and with that and a few new night
modes photos that were literally
impossible a few years ago are now just
effortless on the latest phones
fingerprint readers are under the
displays 65 watt fast chargers bring a
battery from 0-100 in half an hour
and yeah phones literally fold in half
now not just like flip phones of the
past but there's a whole first
generation of fitting a larger display
in your pocket than you ever could
before because the displays are flexible
along with the devices built around them
there's even more on the horizon that
we're looking forward to the cameras in
the front going behind the display glass
we look forward to wireless charging
getting better wireless audio getting
better
5g just to name a few so here's another
version of that question to consider
have we reached peak car
it's actually a very similar question
and when you zoom out again going from
not having cars to having automobiles
suddenly was this massive step and every
new piece that was added every new
feature was a major game change that I
could drive this young new product
category forward so long ago now though
in 2019 what is a car really I mean they
all have four wheels they all have an
engine in the front and a trunk in the
back and a steering wheel and some seats
right so are we at peak car I mean yeah
you can say we're at peak car we've done
the same curve and we've plateaued the
same way but you have to be careful not
to ignore all the newest bleeding edge
innovations and all the things that are
enabled from them specifically the
electric car revolution and what that
means for sustainability what that means
for autonomy what that means for
performance you know the rivey and r1t
and the quad motor tank turn what that
means for features Tesla's worldwide
supercharging network and everything
that is the cyber truck so you have to
say we're at peak car is technically
true we've done the same plateau we've
seen the curve but it still ignores a
lot of the most exciting revolutionary
parts of that industry and so to say
we've reached peak smartphone same thing
it's technically true yes but I think
when you say that you start to ignore
all the crazy newest stuff we've gotten
the the computational photography the
bezel is OLED displays and the whole
folding and half thing here is a the
ridiculous rumoured spec list of the
galaxy s 20 ultra coming up a huge 120
Hertz AMOLED display edge-to-edge a
snapdragon 865 and up to 16 gigs of ram
half a terabyte of flash storage with
the micro SD card so expandable up to
another terabyte a 5000 milliamp hour
wireless and fast charging battery and a
hundred and eight megapixel primary
camera and four others and that's not to
mention whatever other stuff they're
building into the software which can
also enhance and improve the experience
and enable new things like not any
single one of these things is
drastically new by itself and none of
these specs will individually enable you
to do
anything crazy knew that you couldn't do
before and your smartphone but that
combination of specs all in one place
all in one phone is new and if you show
that spec sheet to someone literally
just three years ago they'd probably
tell you it was impossible so when
people ask are we at peak smartphone
right now yes but no we've clearly
reached a point where people don't need
to buy a new thousand dollar phone every
single year over a year and we've
reached a point where software updates
are getting better phones just last
longer now people can use a three or
four year old phone and do everything is
still need to without upgrading to the
bleeding edge stuff but don't forget
about that bleeding edge
don't forget about galaxy fold - or the
cyber truck you know that's still
happening don't let that plateau make
you ignore all the incredible
innovations still happening in these
industries that are driving us forward
or you might miss it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one peace